It belonged to my teacher, Master Yoda.
If you choose the armor, you'll return
to your friend, The Mandalorian.
But if you choose the lightsaber, you
will be the first student in my academy.
Which do you choose?
Welcome back, everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my Mandalorian Season
three Video about Grogu.
Why he left Luke Skywalker's
Jedi Academy so fast.
It seems like he wasn't there that long.
Jon Favreau clarified some of this,
and it has a lot to do with the way
that they're using Grogu on the show
in the way that he's sort of a nexus point
between the Mandalorian culture
and the Jedi culture.
And Mando has the darksaber he's trying
to bring together all the Mandalorians.
There are also
some practical concerns, too,
with the way they move the story
through each of the different series,
because Jon Favreau,
who came from the Marvel movies
like he did the first two Iron Man movies
he executive produced
the first three Avengers
movies through Avengers, Endgame
and he's happy.
Hogan In the Spider-Man movies,
he also explained how he modeled a lot
of the way The Mandalorian Series works
with all the crossovers
in that part of the timeline.
We call it the Mando verse technically,
but it's a Soka book of Boba Fett,
the Skeleton Crew series
all taking place in a shared universe
around that time period in the way
time passes.
So there were a couple of surprises.
Like he wasn't with Luke Skywalker
for the amount of time
that people thought
that he was with Luke Skywalker.
The Mandalorian Season
three episodes are starting this week.
Of course
I'll do videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them all.
It is going to be crazy.
I'll do a special giveaway
in all my episode videos too,
like I've done in previous seasons.
But here's the big surprise
that Jon Favreau
revealed about the Mandalorian timeline
after Return of the Jedi
and how quickly things are moving along
since season one.
You know, he is definitely somebody
who has spent time in both worlds.
And we know that he started off earlier
in the Jedi Temple.
We've seen flashbacks to that.
And then we know that he's been rescued
and spent many years with The Mandalorian,
went back with with Luke.
Now we've been two years apart from him.
Their training.
What's interesting is that as he chooses
to return to his friend, The Mandalorian,
because he's developed an attachment, it's
interesting how that echoes, in a way,
Luke's path when he was, you know,
was drawn to the attachment to his friends
and how that helped shape the future.
And what is the relationship
of those two civilizations?
Because the Mandalorian Armor,
as David's taught me,
was developed to counteract
all of the natural abilities
that the Jedi had
and made it a more level playing field.
So we have a lot to draw
from both from the Clone Wars,
where they both cooperated and fought.
And we also have ancient history, as
we saw in games and in extended universe.
So in that clip, Jon Favreau reveals
it's actually been many years
since the events of season one. He's
going to vague.
When he says many years,
I think he means to say 4 to 5 years.
And he confirms that Grogu,
who was with Luke Skywalker
training at his Jedi Academy
for two years,
which is way longer than I think
people assumed
because it seemed like he was only there
for a hot minute.
And generally
the seasons of The Mandalorian Series
and all these spinoffs are meant to happen
the same way that the Marvel movies
and the Marvel Disney
Plus series move in relatively close
to real time one right after the other.
Season one came in 2019.
Season three episodes are coming in 2023,
so it's about four years.
It's been a little bit longer than that
in the universe of The Mandalorian
and Star Wars right now, Grogu left
with Luke Skywalker to begin his Jedi
training in Mando
had left with the Darksaber
to find the armor
and his former cover to Mandalorians
because he still has the darksaber
that effectively gives him a claim
to the throne of their home planet
Mandalore in the title of Mandalore,
which is what they call
the ruler of their people at any
given time in Grogu who had been training
with Luke Skywalker on the planet
where he eventually creates
his Jedi temple, his academy
that we've seen in the movies.
Luke barely having just begun to construct
the actual physical temple itself.
And he had intended for Grogu
to become his very first student
at the New Jedi Academy.
Even though so
Cayetano was also at the Jedi Academy.
They weren't trying to say
that she was going to become an instructor
at the academy.
She was just there for a brief
stay to meet with Luke Skywalker and see
Grogu begin his training
and then go off on her own mission
that we'll cover during the Ahsoka episodes
and that series next year.
Just because Luke Skywalker
is beginning his new Jedi
Academy doesn't mean that Ahsoka is coming
back to the Jedi Order.
And that's meant
to dovetail with the reason why Grogu,
who decided to leave the Jedi order
and go back to Mando.
It was a great episode.
It featured a lot of Easter eggs
and callbacks to Luke Skywalker's Jedi
training with Yoda during Empire Strikes
Back in a lot of the exact same scenes
running around in the little Yoda
sized backpack, learning to levitate,
balancing himself, using the force
while doing multiple things
at the same time, him learning
to dodge the training drones Blaster
fire was more of a reference
to Yoda's force
jumping and lightsaber fighting skills
during Attack of the Clones
and Revenge of the Sith.
And for Obi-Wan Kenobi's
training of Luke during a new hope
including the size matters not speech.
This is them showing you
some of the things that Grogu can do.
We saw some of his skills
during the Mandalorian season two,
like force choking
and throwing around the stormtroopers.
So he is very powerful
and Luke was helping him unlock
a lot of his prior training with the Jedi
that he's suppressed is Jon Favreau
said Grogu's training with Luke Skywalker,
then choosing to leave
is meant to be a parallel
for Luke Skywalker
training with Yoda in Empire Strikes Back.
They're getting
the force vision of his friends
in trying to leave to go save them.
And even though Grogu didn't get a force
vision of Mando being in trouble
during the episode, they try to show you
how Ahsoka had to counsel
Mando about Jedi attachment issues
and remind him what it did.
And again, Skywalker leaning to him,
becoming Darth Vader,
going to the dark side of the force.
She basically explained why she and Luke
Skywalker were trying to do
everything they could
to avoid repeating that mistake.
And at the end of the episode,
they show Grogu,
who is just as preoccupied missing Mando,
not focusing on his training
as much as he should,
which is also meant to be another parallel
for Mannequin Skywalker.
Yoda had his own version of this speech
during Empire Strikes Back, speaking about
and again, Skywalker and Luke Skywalker,
like his father, however,
his mind on where he was,
what he was doing,
that's what his focus comment
about Anik and Skywalker
meant when she told Luke,
Much like your father,
the double meaning was that she was saying
that Luke was much like his father
trying to train
a Padawan for the first time,
like Ahsoka was in a sense, first Padawan.
But Ahsoka was also telling Luke that
she sees a lot of the same energy
and grogu you that she saw on Mannequin
Skywalker, which is kind of a warning.
And this dovetails with a few reasons
why they had Grogu
leave Luke Skywalker's Jedi Academy
and his training and go back to Mando.
Within the story, they're using Grogu
as a sort of inflection point,
like a nexus point between
Mandalorian culture and Jedi culture.
And they're trying to use Mando
with the Darksaber,
which is a Jedi artifact
created by the first Mandalorian Jedi
to unite all the mandalorians
the same way their ancestor TAA Vizsla,
the very first Mandalorian Jedi, used
the darksaber in his abilities as Jedi
training to unite all their people.
So even though Mando is being viewed
as the person to unite all these people
or have to do it, really, it's grogu
that the show is going to use to help
unite all these different Mandalorians.
Also, there's the idea that Grogu
will become a mandalorian Jedi,
just like TAA Vizsla,
just not biologically a mandalorian.
The whole idea with Mandalorians like din
djarin is that he wasn't born
a mandalorian. He chose to become one.
And it sounds like that's
what they're doing with Grogu
who he will choose to be part
of the Mandalorians with Mando,
like a family with Mando.
Even the armor basically called him Grogu,
whose father you are as his father.
For now.
In the bigger, lower kind of way, it's
all about the mistakes of the Jedi
and how their dogma set them up to fail
during the prequels.
Like we talk about the Fall of the Jedi
and as evil as Emperor Palpatine
and the Sith were a lot of the things
that the Jedi wound up doing.
A lot of their teachings
were actually wrong,
just in a completely different direction.
George
Lucas talked a lot about this, about
and again, Skywalker
bringing balance to the force.
And as much as that was about getting rid
of the emperor during Return of the Jedi,
bringing balance to the force
was also about getting rid of the Jedi
order as it existed when and again,
Skywalker became Darth Vader.
The idea that even though
the Jedi themselves weren't evil,
a lot of their teachings were wrong.
At the end of the episode,
Luke Skywalker forces Grogu
to make the choice
between the Mandalorian in the Jedi.
I choose the Mandalorians beskar
armor chainmail suit or choose
Yoda lightsaber in the Path of the Jedi.
If he chooses the armor
he forsakes the Path of the Jedi as Luke
Skywalker sees it,
and if he chooses Yoda's lightsaber, Luke
is effectively saying,
You won't ever see The Mandalorian again.
It will take you many years
to master the ways of force
and you may never see
The Mandalorian again.
A lot of you were commenting about
how it's lame for Luke to make him choose.
Like, why make him choose?
Why can't he have both the armor
and the lightsaber?
And the reason why they actually wrote it
this way, why they had Luke Skywalker do
this is to show you how Lucas
repeating a lot of the same mistakes
as the Jedi Order
with their rigid dogma about attachments
and he sort of setting up his Jedi academy
to eventually fail.
Remember during episode five,
when Mando had the Darksaber
and was talking to the armor about Grogu
and she told him the same speech
about Jedi dogma and attachments?
Mando argued that their philosophy
as Mandalorians was almost the opposite.
It was all about attachment and protecting
your clan, protecting your family.
That is the opposite of our creed.
Loyalty and
solidarity are the way in your
to remember that Mando is not on the path
to the dark side or anything
like he's a little bit darker
as a character,
but they want you to think that he's
walking the correct path,
like he might make some short
term mistakes, but in the larger
sense of things, he's on the right path.
Whereas Luke Skywalker is just repeating
the same mistakes of the old Jedi Order.
We saw how that ended not
well in while Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni
aren't retconning any of the new Star Wars
movies or anything,
they are preemptively sidestepping them
using grogu you.
And here's how they're doing that.
Luke helped him unlock his previous Jedi
training, making him much more powerful,
giving him access to more memories
that he can continue to relearned Jedi
skills from.
So he's just beginning to do that now.
And because Yoda's species lives
for up to 900 years or so
grogu's only a little over 50
now he's got over 800 years
to develop his own version
of a new Jedi Order
that's totally different
from the old Jedi Order.
So in choosing the best score armor,
they're basically saying Grogu,
who is going to reject
the old Jedi ways that Luke Skywalker
is hyping up in this episode?
So eventually, someday, when Mando dies,
either of old age or he dies
in some big battle in Grogu,
who goes his own way, focusing more on
deepening his connection with the force,
he'll start a new Jedi order of his own.
And because this is more than 50
plus years in the future
we're probably talking about here,
unless Mando gets killed really soon,
that puts Grogu way past the events
of the new star Wars movies,
effectively sidestepping everything
that happened during the new movies.
Grogu off on his own
with the help of Force Ghost Yoda
maybe counseling him or anybody that's
still alive at that point, maybe Force
Ghost, Ahsoka Pretty much all the Jedi
that you know right now would be a force
ghost by that point.
Right now, Grogu,
who is the only character
that we know of that we've seen
in the context of the show in the movies,
who would still be alive a long time
in the future, creating a new, different
Jedi Academy, one that doesn't focus
so much on absolutes or attachment issues.
There were a lot of jokes about this, too,
after Luke Skywalker
made him choose Why is he making him
choose only Sith deal in absolutes.
If you haven't seen any of the Star Wars
Rebels episodes either, They introduced
the Bender character
during that played by Tom
Baker of Doctor Who fame in the band
who was a creature that wasn't a Jedi.
Or is it?
He wasn't a great Jedi either,
but he wielded both the dark side
and the light side of the force
in a more complete way.
That made him way more powerful.
And I think that eventually,
in the distant future of the Star Wars
universe, Grogu will become something
closer to the Bindu.
Even if he doesn't become a die
bender himself.
Die Bender is the name of the order
that the bend do belong to
is Big East Egg for that,
which is actually a big Easter egg
for George Lucas's origin
or treatment from the Star Wars universe.
For those of you
wondering
if Grogu would ever go back to pick up
Yoda's lightsaber,
like would Luke's to let him have it,
I'd rather see him
create his own lightsaber eventually.
This is totally different,
even though he doesn't have the technical
knowledge in how to actually build
a lightsaber force ghost Yoda or Ahsoka.
Tano could teach him how to do that.
If you saw the deleted scenes
for Return of the Jedi,
they also had the deleted scene of Luke
Skywalker
building his new green lightsaber.
He didn't get special plans
in how to build that.
He got some help from Force
Ghost Obi-Wan Kenobi in Yoda
so they can do the same thing for Grogu,
who in the distant future
when he eventually creates his own
lightsaber.
Also, Ahsoka
Tano would know how to build a lightsaber.
She could tell Grogu how to do that too.
So there are other force
users out there who are still alive.
The Grogu who can still learn new things
from while he's
having adventures with The Mandalorian
during season three and beyond.
But if you've any more questions
about what Grogu
was doing with Luke Skywalker,
how long he was with them,
how much training Luke Skywalker
unlocked in him,
just write it below in the comments.
My Full Mandalorian Season three episode
one video we'll post next On Wednesday.
It'll be Wednesday.
Every single week there'll be eight
episodes just like previous seasons.
Everyone click here
for My Mandalorian Season
three Episode one Video Update the link
As soon as I post that and click here
for all my Mandalorian videos.
Thank you so much for watching. Everyone.
Stay safe.
And this is the way.